they certainly did do it and now we're
going to unpick at all let's Lucy Carter
again you were furiously adding up with
your little tally who's got the most so
who's got the most nods
I'm hoping these arrived they're roughly
like age they can't be that big can't be
that bad and I think Irishman has got
the top with 11 along with Joker
followed by 1917 and Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood both with tan so I think
probably quite as expected no massive
surprises and then also up there doing
incredibly well we've got parasite with
six two Pope's has only got three but I
think that was quite surprising we
weren't expecting that many Jo Jo rabbit
six Little Women six as well so I wasn't
expecting Little Women to get that many
but nothing for Greta cos up for
original screenplay adapted screenplay
adapted screen only something best
picture but yeah it would be great to
see a Best Director wouldn't it yeah I
think the stat line is something like
and in the 91 years that the Oscars have
been doing this only five women have
been nominated and that number has not
increased now with this nominations
which is a bit disappointing I think
little woman is very deserving of that
knowledge she forgot to go but she'd
have fantastic job I mean it is the
problem of little women that it is a
story that has been told many times and
in many films it's not original in that
sense it's an original adaptation of it
I totally agree with you I kind of think
that it's a beautiful story it's a
beautiful film and the acting is
fantastic it's great to see such a ronin
and and Florence Pugh both been
nominated but in terms of the direction
I I don't I don't know whether it's it's
up there for me with Martin Scorsese and
some of the others like and 1917 I mean
it was it just blew me away in terms of
how original how different and I'm not
sure that Greta Gerwig sits there for me
this year but it's very very
disappointing I mean the via the Academy
has said that it will do better in terms
of women and diversity the industry as a
whole have said that they will do better
but that's still not translating well
enough for people it's it's not good
enough as er let's talk about 1917 James
order do you think of it
loved it for it's brilliant I mean it's
on the one hand a lot of people are
talking about the sort of the the
technical aspect of it the fact that it
appears to be one continuous shot which
we know that it's not but that's
certainly how it looks but you know
aside from the technical aspect of it
it's incredibly emotional incredibly
dramatic you'll bear with these
characters in northern France in the
trenches in no-man's land so it's really
a case of the technical aspect of the
film serving the drama and helping with
the characters it's got a clip but
actually let's just listening your
orders are to get to the second at quasi
word one mile southeast of the town of
request deliver this to Colonel McKenzie
it is a direct order to call off
tomorrow monix attack if you don't it
will be a massacre we will lose two
battalions 1,600 men your brother among
them do you think you can get there in
time yes sir and Colin Firth isn't up
there for Best Actor for it but you
think 1917 does really stand a chance in
best film I think it does I think if
there's a new James is absolutely right
technically a super film I was watching
it and every 15 minutes I was like how
did they do that
so yeah especially if it's had a good
awards season
it's won a couple of awards in that
regard already so yeah that the hype is
good for it and I could definitely see
it taking on that one Once Upon a Time
in America that was that this is that
the second largest nominated once upon a
time in Hollywood Hollywood sorry yeah
ten and again this is Quentin Tarantino
we were expecting it to get lots of nods
and but I think again well we expecting
it to be as undiversified
I mean I was hoping for a few surprises
and it did play out pretty much as we
talked about you know before the
nominations unfortunately and it would
have been I mean there's a film called
the farewell for example that came out
last summer there was a film I loved and
and it's got you know good good critics
reviews
aquafina was the star
when was the director and they were in
some award ceremony so I was hoping that
that might carry through to the Oscars
it hasn't I know you were hoping for
Ward's for the film a song go again it's
had some nominations but has never
really been a front-runner didn't come
through today so yes it's great that you
know man Scorsese is nominated again of
course he's a legend Quentin Tarantino
but this is pretty much what we were
expecting yeah the Peeta is the one that
really hurts me because for me and
there's the best performance by an
actress I've seen in the past 12 months
or so the degree of difficulty with that
role is extreme and she pulled it off
masterfully so I was really really
hoping that she'd bet some awards love
from the Oscars but not to be